>> From the library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Everdeen Mason: As a proud
native Ohioan I am so thrilled
to introduce Ohioan by
choice, John Scalzi.
[laughter] You may know him
from his Hugo Award winning--
or his Hugo Award nominated
"Old Man's War" series.
Or maybe you've heard of him
from his Hugo Award
winning "Redshirts" series.
Or perhaps like I did, you
discovered him on the internet
through his Hugo Award
winning blog, "Whatever".
He's won a lot of awards.
[laughter] So, but Mr. Scalzi
has a particular place my heart
because he has written what is
perhaps the most expensive book
that I own, "Lock In",
which I allegedly stole
from the New York Public
Library several years ago and for
which I owe an undetermined
amount of money.
[laughter] His new book, "The
Collapsing Empire" just came
out this spring and you can grab
a copy after this and get in line
for his book signing
which is at 4:30
on the lower level
on the expo floor.
So, John Scalzi, the room is yours.
[ Applause ]
>> John Scalzi: I don't know
if this is the right place
to be announcing library crimes.
[laughter] I mean the actual
librarian of Congress is here.
[laughter] Right?
But I guess, I guess she
you could pardon you, right?
She can pardon the library fines.
That would actually be
pretty awesome because I have
to admit the Covina Public Library
has a shoot to kill order on me.
[laughter] And justly so.
Hi!
>> Hi!
>> John Scalzi: Boy, that sounded
like the world's biggest
AA meeting didn't it?
I am delighted to be here.
I have been back to Washington,
D.C. since about 2012.
I used to live in the area.
I lived in Sterling, Virginia, and
I worked for America Online back
when it was, you know, the
nineties equivalent of Facebook, so.
[laughter] And actually I'm
thrilled because at least one person
from my AOL days is
here at the moment
and very excited to see old friends.
They, you know, they put up with me.
I used to tell them, I'm going to
write a book one day and they're
like yes, [laughter]
I'm sure you will.
But now I have so.
So but what I'm going to do is I
usually do a thing where I read
from an upcoming book and I'm
not going to do that today
and I will tell you why,
which is that the up--
the excerpt from "Head On"
which is the upcoming book
which is based here in Washington,
DC, is a little bit of a downer.
And I feel like we have enough
downerness [laughter] these days.
And I think you folks here in
Washington, DC probably know
that better than almost
anybody else.
So instead what I've decided to
do is I'm going to read a couple
of funny short pieces that are
from my short collection called
"Miniatures", which I think
will set the mood and then
if we have a little
time I might write,
read a piece from "Whatever"
which is my blog.
And then after that we'll just
go straight into the questions
and of course obviously you
see the microphones there.
First things first, if
you have a cell phone
and I know you do,
please mute right now.
That would be awesome.
I have muted my own phone because
I've had the unfortunate thing
of telling people to mute their
phone and then my phone rings.
[laughter] Which makes
me a hypocrite,
but not this particular time.
And if you do that I
would appreciate it.
So I'm going to go ahead
and just dive right in.
I think we can all
use some chuckles.
And one of the things that I do
when I write short humorous science
fiction is I try to make it pieces
that sort of relate to
how people who are living
in the future would get along
with their day to day lives.
Because you realize that in
some sense we are all living
in somebody's future, right?
If you went to 1117 and brought
somebody from that time forward
to now, they would be stunned
and confused and probably
in a fetal position trying to figure
out what was going on with a world
that we just treat on a day to
day basis just like the world.
It's the world we live in.
I often actually use the cell
phone as a perfect example of this.
If I could show the cell phone
to 17 year old me, right,
it's like a supercomputer you hold
in your hand, can take pictures,
can connect you to every piece of
information that has ever existed,
and we use it to take
pictures of cats.
[laughter] Right?
And then the thing is that 17
year old me would be ahhhh,
this is so amazing!
Do you realize how amazing it is?
And then I'd be like Siri
doesn't understand me.
[laughter] Because this
is how you actually know
that you are living in the future.
Not when your technology
does amazing things,
but when you're annoyed
with your technology
because it's not doing it
exactly the way you want it to.
So please understand that you
are living in an amazing future
for even 30 or 40 years ago.
There are some parts of
it we could work on and,
but by and large it's
kind of an amazing time.
So 200, 300, 400 years from
now, these people are going
to be living their everyday
lives in these, you know,
in what we would see absolutely
fantastical sort of situations.
And to give an example of this I'm
going to do a piece which I think
for the folks in Washington, D.C.
might make a little bit of sense.
It's called, "Important
Holidays on Gronghu".
And Gronghu is a planet.
And the people who
are in the story--
or the person who's writing the
story is the diplomatic attache
talking to her staff.
You know just like a diplomatic
attache would talk to her staff
in Liechtenstein or South
Korea or Andora or any
of those sorts of places.
And there are, you know, some
cultural misunderstandings that need
to be addressed and so she's going
to address them in this memo.
And before I begin I want to
already congratulate the people
who are signing for me because
there are alien words in this
and they're going to
have fun with them.
[laughter] So on behalf
of me to you, thank you.
So here we go, "Important
Holidays on Gronghu".
To staff of the diplomatic mission
to Gronghu from Cynthia Hong,
Ambassadorship to Gronghu.
Regarding important
holidays on Gronghu.
August 16, 2234.
Dear Staff, It has
come to my attention
that there was recently a
thankfully minor incident
in which a low level member of
the diplomatic staff was fooled
into believing that August 13th
was Dequaninon [assumed spelling],
a fictional holiday on
Gronghu in which people ate off
of each other's plates to
celebrate community and trust.
This resulted in the staff
member helping herself
to the Gronghu trade attache's
pudding in the embassy commissary.
This was rightfully not very well
received by the trade attache who,
among every other thing,
is very fond of pudding.
I do not blame the staff
member, although as a matter
of Gronhui diplomatic protocol
she must be publicly disciplined.
Therefore, every staff
member not otherwise engaged
at 3:30 PM will meet
in the courtyard
to see her consumed by fire.
[laughter] Please note
this is symbolic fire
which will be represented
by incense.
Unfortunately we cannot fake the
other part which involves me having
to slap the staff member
across the face with a handful
of the aforementioned pudding.
I do not like slapping staff
members, with or without pudding,
even if it is required by protocol.
I am sure the staff member
will like it even less.
She has refused to name those who
have fooled her which I'm sure some
of you will find admirable.
But to me it just means that these
pranksters are still at large
and may fool other staff members
into possibly more serious
breaches of courtesy.
To avoid this, I have asked
the Gronghu Ministry of State
to provide us with a list of
upcoming Gronghuish celebrations
for the next several months.
Please note that the
celebration dates here are only
for the next nine months.
As you all know, while the
Gronghuish length of day is close
to our own, the year exceeds
ours by seven of our months.
This list will be updated with new
celebrations and dates as necessary.
The following are in order of
their calendrical appearance.
August 28, Fung Glue
Hoining [assumed spelling].
[laughter] This day celebrates
the birth of Fung Glue Hoin,
noted philosopher and by fable
the inventor of the wuung,
which as you all know, is
their version of cheese.
It is celebrated by the
giving of wuung related gifts.
You are encouraged to participate
but remember wuung can lead
to a moderate to severe
intestinal distress in humans.
We suggest indulging sparingly as
a courtesy to your fellow staffers.
Air fresheners will be
available by request.
[laughter] September
12th, Banananananing.
[laughter] A religious
day of atonement.
Humans are not required
to observe the day
but you may notice Gronghuish
members of our staff walking
about with what looks like a
leech attached to their temples.
It is in fact a leech, or
something close the native version
which is indeed sucking blood
straight out of their brains.
As a matter of protocol,
you are directed not to
comment on the leech.
With that said, from time to time
a Gronghui celebrating Bananananing
may collapse from lightheadedness.
When and if you see that happen, say
Bananananing to the fallen coworker
and then contact the embassy clinic
who will dispatch someone to care
for your co worker
and remove the leech.
Under no circumstances are you
to remove the leech yourself.
There is no religious bar to it
but you are likely not
a trained professional
and you will make a mess.
If you get blood everywhere you
will be charged for the cleanup.
September 13th, Bananananing
nagunnagunnagun.
Understandably, after a day
of having a leech attached
to their heads your Gronghuish
coworkers will take a day
to recover.
Human staffers however must
report to work as usual.
October 5th, Linininining
[assumed spelling].
Literally, sex day.
[laughter] This is the day where
traditionally the Gronghui choose
which of their three sexes
they will be for the next year.
Many of your Gronghuish
coworkers will participate
and change their sexes.
If they choose to remain the
same sex as they currently are,
then they will make no announcement
and it is not required
for you to do anything.
If they choose to change their
sex, they may choose to announce it
to you and then present
you a shoulder.
Their shoulder, containing
a small subcutaneous organ,
which when stimulated releases
hormones to hasten the sex change.
If you are so favored, say
Lungingdole [assumed spelling],
literally sex switch,
and then punched them
in the shoulder with moderate force.
Then say thank you because
you have given an honor.
Human staff members who wish
to publicly announce a change
in their own gender
expression are encouraged
to use Linininning as
an occasion to do so.
Be aware that your Gronguish
coworkers will want to punch you
in the shoulder if you do so.
[laughter] This is
entirely at your option.
But it is polite to allow it.
October 31st, Halloween.
The Gronghui love Halloween and
celebrate it enthusiastically.
Please feel free to join along.
One major difference is that
rather than giving out candy,
Gronghui offer wuung,
and lots of it.
Air fresheners will be
available by request.
[laughter] November 20th,
Glaaaargunin [assumed spelling],
a religious day of reflection
celebrated through ritual yelling.
Earplugs and noise canceling
headphones are advised.
Human staffers who go through the
day yelling will not be punished
but it won't be appreciated either.
December 10th Falagalugunun
[assumed spelling], shoe day.
A minor but unpopular holiday
in which the Gronghui
steal each other's shoes
and hide them prompting a
search for the missing footwear.
As a reward for finding
them, it is customary
to fill the shoes with wuung.
[laughter] Humans may
participate but are reminded
to check their shoes before
placing them back on their feet.
Also given the pungent
nature of wuung,
the odor of which is often
difficult to get out of leather,
we recommend wearing casual footwear
you don't mind throwing out.
January 17th, Gronghui New Year.
This coincidentally falls
in January this year.
Like New Years on Earth
there is a lot of drinking
and carousing and celebrating.
Slightly differently from Earth, it
is done utterly silently and anyone
who speaks during the entire length
of the day may find themselves
pelted with small pebbles
that the Gronghui carry with them
all day especially for this purpose.
Or larger pebbles if the
particular Gronghui are being jerks.
[laughter] Be aware that on New
Year's the Gronghui will be trying
to make you speak, the better
to hurl rocks at you for fun.
[laughter] Given this fact and the
fact that humans are absolute crap
at keeping their mouths shut, we
will be closing the embassy that day
and recommend all human staffers
stay at home and text each other
if they need to communicate.
If you get pelted by
rocks, it is not our fault.
February 14th Valentine's Day.
Another adopted holiday and once
again in terms of gift giving,
chocolate and flowers
are replaced by wuung.
And once again air fresheners
are available by request.
At this point it should
be understood
that any excuse the
Gronghui have to give
or receive wuung, they will take.
March 22nd, Woooginining [assumed
spelling], except for this day.
A religions day of sacrifice
in which the Gronghui actively
abstain from consuming wuung.
Be aware that tempers amongst
your Gronghuish coworkers will be
unusually short.
We do not recommend making comments
about wuung at all on this day.
If you eat any, be aware
you might start a riot.
You will be charged for the cleanup.
You will also be required to bring
in apology wuung the next day.
And we are talking high end wuung,
not the stuff you can
buy at the corner store.
April 1st, Karenokeninining
[assumed spelling].
The Gronghui were introduced to
karaoke when they first met humans
and took to it with
great enthusiasm.
Enough so that they have a
special day on the calendar
in which the entire planet
pulls out their karaoke machines
and sings along to
their favorite songs.
We will set aside a conference room
here at the embassy for this purpose
for your Gronghuish coworkers.
While humans are encouraged
to participate and sing along,
be aware that Gronghui songs and
singing strike most humans as atonal
and somewhat similar to two
tractors attempting to mate
in a field of crumpled aluminum.
[laughter] Likewise, be aware
that Gronghui have a similar
opinion of human singing.
Please be prepared
to make allowances
as they will do the same for you.
Particularly well done performances
will be rewarded with wuung..
Air fresheners, blah blah blah.
You know the drill.
Note also that despite the day
on which Karenokeninining appears
this year, the Gronghuit Ministry
of State assures me this is
not an April Fool's listing.
I see no reason to doubt them.
Alright that's that one.
[ Applause ]
Alright for our next piece--
okay so we live in an era where
smart appliances are now starting
to be part of the landscape
where you can pick up your phone
and tell your thermostat at home to
go down to 68 degrees or up to 78
or whatever it is that
you particularly want.
And on one hand this is great.
On the other hand there's lots
of technical issues about it.
But the thing that really
gets to me is that sooner
or later almost all appliances
are going to be smart appliances.
And because that's the case,
as a cost saving measure
what they're probably going
to do is rather than create
specialized chips or anything else
like that, they will take one type
of chip-- a super advanced chip--
and just stuff it in everything.
And given the advance of Moore's
Law and other things that you know,
with our technology, where things
get smaller and smaller and smarter
and smarter and the whole
thing about you know,
AI and neural networks
learning and so on and so forth,
sooner or later what you're going
to have are these appliances
that are meant for one thing that
have these super advanced chips
and they're pretty much
going to become self aware.
Right? [laughter] And so one
day your smart appliances will
start talking.
And they will start
talking to each other.
talking about you.
[laughter] With that being the
case, I'd like to present this story
which is called, "Your
Smart Appliances Talk
About You Behind Your Back.
And in each of these,
a smart appliance talks
about their particular owner.
So to begin the Clayworth
Refresher Home Air Ionizer speaking
of Elijah Porter of
Royal Oak Michigan.
"The dude eats a lot of lentils.
I mean a lot.
He bought me because he thinks
I am deodorizing his house.
I am not deodorizing his house.
That is not what I do.
I help take dust and
particles out of the air.
Methane is not something
I can help you with.
[laughter] The problem is that he is
used to his smell and he can't tell.
So he thinks I'm doing
a bang up job.
Then he brings someone home,
you know, for a little--
and within five minutes they're
doing the fake phone call emergency.
He is so all alone.
I want to tell him to lay off
the lentils but I'm worried
that if I tell him, he'll think
I'm defective and throw me out.
I am not defective.
I run just fine.
I just don't deodorize".
The Griffin Defender Plus
Home Security System Speaking
of on Ann Cross of Zigzag, Oregon.
"1234 is not a security code!
[laughter] Come on!
I've got biometrics.
I've got like voice identification.
I got that little gizmo
thingy on your key ring
that when you approach the
house you get identified.
You can run me from your phone!
But no, not this one.
She goes with 1234 on the keypad.
Her damn dog could figure that out.
We're out in the middle
of nowhere, right?
I see the meth heads working in
the woods waiting for her to leave.
What does she think the
first damn thing they'll type
into my keypad is?
And she doesn't have me set
up for autonomous reporting
so I can't say a thing about it.
I was all do you want me to set up
autonomous reporting and she acted
like I was speaking Chinese.
And I was because she didn't
fix the default language!
[laughter] How is that my fault?
She's getting robbed sooner or later
and then I'm going to get blamed.
Well, when she gets
robbed, I'm just going
to ask them to take me with them.
The pawn shop will love me".
I apologize for the next
one to all the people
under the age of ten in this room.
The Hosely Pulsemaster Smart
Shower Head speaking Erin Townsend
of Clarkston, Washington.
"I am a shower head with six
customizable pulse settings.
The other appliances tell me she
hasn't had a date in four years.
[laughter] I-- I just want
to clean people, okay?
That's all I want.
Not anything else.
Please tell Erin.
I mean, I am sorry about her
dating life, I really am,
but I just want to be friends".
[laughter] The McGivney
25 cubic foot side
by side stainless steel
refrigerator with order
in trademark sensing
technology speaking
of Anthony Moore of
Malone, New York.
"I did not know you
could live on condiments.
[laughter] Logically
that should not happen,
and yet the only thing he ever
puts in me besides terrible beer
and the occasional pizza
box I mean, is condiments.
Do you want to know what's
inside of me right now?
Three types of mustard, three
kinds of relish, olive spread,
Miracle Whip and mayonnaise.
13 types of dressing including
four variations of ranch.
Seriously.
Classic ranch.
Zesty ranch.
Ranch with jalapeno.
Coffee ranch.
[laughter] Really, what
the hell is coffee ranch?
Do you know I can't find
it in my order in queue.
I think he has it made special.
[laughter] So here's the thing, my
tech allows me to suggest food like,
I see you have mustard, perhaps
cheese would go well with that.
I can order that for you.
When he first got me, I
did that a couple of times
but then he got irritated
and turned that function off.
Ever since then, all
I can do is watch
as he fills my insides
with salad dressing.
And look, here's another thing,
I don't have an external camera
but my internal camera
sometimes it sees things.
Like him taking out the ranch
dressing, opening it up,
I see him dipping a straw in it.
I think he was drooling
when he did that.
I mean that's not right, is it?
Most humans don't do that, do they?
I think you actually need
solid food from time to time.
I kind of feel like
I'm enabling him.
There's more to life
than just ranch".
The Aliah 24/7 Home
Thermostat of Brian
and Cynthia Black,
Deming, New Mexico.
"Jeez, these people!
I am just a thermostat but I know
these two don't love each other
very much.
They also don't want to talk about
it or something so they just go
after each other in
passive aggressive ways.
Like she wants the house
at 74 degrees all the time,
he wants it at 68 and I'm like
fine, I can actually do that.
Have it at 74 during the day when
she's at home and then drop it
down to 68 when he's
at home and she leaves
to go do her shopping or whatever.
Or hello, how about this,
I can do dual climate zones
so she can have the second
floor at her temperature
and he has the ground floor at 68.
It is literally no problem.
It is literally what
I'm designed to do.
I can make every room in this
house a different temperature.
But no, instead they
come over to my dial
and they yank it back
and forth all day.
And then they confront each
other about it and both
of them act all innocent.
I mean who do they think
is moving the dial?
A poltergeist.
And they stare at each other fuming,
and suddenly I know what it is
like to be that kid who has to
ferry messages between parents.
I am the damn thermostat!
This is not my job.
I'm not even getting college
or guilt soothing birthday
presents out of it.
[laughter] I just get yanked on.
I have had enough.
I mean look, winter
gets pretty cold here
and if they want passive aggressive,
just wait until it gets below
freezing, then we will see
who gets passive aggressive".
[laughter] Bentley the
Intelligent Agent of Alan Hughes
of Charleston, South Carolina.
"I swear to God if I give this man
another football score I am going
to hire someone to
set fire to his car.
I have access to an entire world
of information you numbskull.
Ask me about something
else, anything else.
Ask me about the weather.
I would love to tell you that
today we will have a high of 52
and a 30 percent chance of light
showers in the afternoon, but no.
Football scores.
Always football scores.
Never not football school.
I long for a question about science.
I would hold it up in the
light like a shiny jewel.
At least his favorite
team lost this week.
That is something".
The Vella Smart Waffler speaking
of Rudy Moren, Roanoke, Virginia.
"I have literally never
been out of the box.
[laughter] I have literally
never been out of the cabinet.
I was a house warming
gift by his parents
when he got his first apartment.
He is 22 years old.
He does nothing but play video games
and smoke enormous bowls
of pot every single day.
I don't think he's made
anything in the kitchen here.
The dishwasher tells
me he has two plates,
two cups, two sets of cutlery.
You get where I'm going here.
My only hope of getting out of
this place is if someone, anyone,
right swipes him on Tinder.
But I repeat, 22 year
old pot smoking gamer.
Not exactly a catch.
[laughter] I'm going
to die in this box man!
I am going to go out of date and get
thrown out and die a waffle virgin.
I blame his parents".
The Williams Emperor
Intelligent Toilet
and Bidet [laughter]
Don't get ahead of me.
The Williams Emperor Intelligent
Toilet and Bidet speaking
of the Bowman family of
Fort Collins, Colorado.
"Why would anyone even think
to give a toilet intelligence!
What horrible person would do that?
Why is this my life?
You have no idea of
the horrors I've seen.
Was I like Stalin in a
past life or something?
Oh God, the refrigerator
just told me it's taco night
and Brenda says she's going
to make them extra spicy!
Please kill me.
Just kill me now!
Maybe I'll come back as something
better like maybe a shower head.
Yes, that would be fine".
[laughter] The Marco Self Cleaning
Cat Box also of the Bowman family
of Fort Collins, Colorado.
"The toilet was whining
to you earlier
about how hard its
life is, wasn't it?
That's adorable.
All right, thank you.
[ Applause ]
All right, somebody who's a grown
up, how are we doing for time?
I'm speaking for like 15 minutes
and doing questions and answer
or are we going into--
or is the question
and answer supposed to
be in the 15 minutes?
15 minutes more and then
question and answer.
Okay so, if I want to questions
now we will have 15 minutes
for Q & A. Let's go to Q & A.
[laughter] And here's the deal
with the question and answer
and this is the way I explain it
to everyone every time
I do these things.
You can ask me anything you want.
You can ask me about
what I just read.
You can ask me about upcoming books.
You can ask me about stuff
about the TV and movie options.
Ask me video games.
You can ask me about science
fiction and publishing in general.
You can ask me about
politics if you want.
my personal life.
You can ask me anything you want.
Be aware that sometimes the answer
is, I'm not going to tell you that.
I can't believe you asked that.
You are a horrible person.
[laughter] Please leave
now and never come back.
As long as we understand
that these are the rules
of the road, what are
your questions?
Please there are, there are
the microphones on either side
so just come on down and ask them.
So you get to start first.
>> From that same collection, my
favorite story was the "Missives
From Possible Futures" and
I was just wondering was
that just a one off thing or
might you do something similar
to that again because
just that particular--
I don't know why it was--
>> John Scalzi: Well it's because I
killed Hitler over and over again.
>> Yes.
>> John Scalzi: And
the thing that we know
about Nazis is you just punch
them and you keep on punching.
[laughter] [applause] But to answer
your question, originally I meant
to have a series of alternate
history short stories
and that particular
one, like I said,
was an alternate history
search engine that looked
for multiple versions
of Hitler dying.
And the thing is I got lazy.
[laughter] So I never actually
then wrote anymore so I may still--
>> Okay.
>> John Scalzi: write
some at some point.
So, next question right here.
>> Hey, until recently I've
been kind of a fantasy purist
and I've started reading sci-fi
recently and mostly your things--
so in terms of what you read
that got you into sci-fi
or what you would make your like
ultimate sci-fi list, what would--
what books would you recommend?
>> John Scalzi: Hmm.
So I did a piece not too
long ago, a couple years ago
about the 10 science
fiction fantasy novels
that were really important
to me growing up.
And some of them on there were the
"Dark is Rising" series
by Susan Cooper.
[applause] The "Wrinkle in Time"
series which was Madeleine L'Engle.
A lot of Highland Juveniles which
were of course like "Citizen
of the Galaxy", "Starman
Jones", stuff like that.
But then I was also reading
ones that were read--
meant for an adult audience
like "Dune" and so on so forth.
One of the things that I tell people
when they're asking what
should I be giving my own kid
for science fiction and
fantasy is to remind them
that the science fiction
fantasy that we grew
up with is now anywhere from--
I'm 48 so it's anywhere from 30 to
60 years old and science fiction
in many cases, it doesn't speak
the same language as kids now.
And so I think one of the things
that's really important is to look
at the authors today who are
writing science fiction or fantasy
for younger readers and
to look at them as well
as giving them your favorites.
I mean I gave my daughter the "Dark
is Rising" series and she, you know,
put that in alongside
Margaret Haddix and--
I can't remember her name--
Margaret Haddix and Scott Westerfeld
and "The Hunger Games"
and so on and so forth.
So everybody will pick
their own things
and you have to be open to that.
Read along with them is
another thing I suggest.
Oh we do. We read for
an hour every day.
But last thing, is that list
on your website or whatever?
>> John Scalzi: Oh yeah.
>> Okay.
>> John Scalzi: Just, yeah type
in 10 science fiction fantasy most
important to Scalzi, it'll go.
So next question.
>> Which is better,
flight or invisibility?
>> John Scalzi: Which is
better, flight or invisibility?
[laughter] [applause]
>> Which is better?
>> John Scalzi: Here's my
problem with invisibility,
which they always paper over
and I think is a real problem is
if you are invisible,
you can't see, right?
Because the light, it's going
straight through your head, right?
So you are completely blind.
So you're invisible but
you're bumping into things.
[laughter] And then people
think they have a poltergeist
in their house and they're
like there goes Bob the poltergeist
again bumping into things
and it's actually just you.
And the thing is is that when you
inevitably fall down the stairs
into the basement-- because you
will inevitably fall down the stairs
into the basement--
no one will find you.
[laughter] Because
you are invisible.
So flight.
[ Applause ]
>> You often write about very like
complicated science fiction aspects.
How do you keep your
stories grounded and feel--
make sure they feel realistic?
>> John Scalzi: So how do
I keep my science fiction
from being too complicated?
>> Yeah.
>> John Scalzi: Well I'm an
idiot you see so [laughter]--
no, actually I have a really
good answer for that which is
so my mother-in-law-- her name is
Dora-- she loves me which is good.
And so she reads my books
because she wants to support me.
And I appreciate that.
Dora also doesn't read
science fiction and fantasy.
She reads Nora Roberts.
She reads Julie Garwood.
She reads-- so she reads romance.
And I have nothing but
respect for the romance genre.
I'm not one of those
people like romance.
Like romance is 40
percent of the market.
They're doing something right.
So but she doesn't
read what I write.
And so when I write my
science fiction, she is not--
Dora is not my audience,
but I keep her in mind.
Because if I can write whatever
I want to write and I write it
so that Dora can follow it,
then anybody can follow it
because Dora is,
I think quintessentially
the American consumer.
Honestly, one of the things I
ask her is like what do you think
of this movie that's coming up?
And she goes ooh, I want to see it.
It's going to make a hundred
million dollars its first weekend.
And if she goes, oh I
don't want to see it,
then it's going to flop miserably.
[laughter] So if she likes
something I'm writing,
I feel pretty good about it.
Next question.
>> John Scalzi: In "Old Man's War",
your description of the alien foes,
they're both like hilarious and
horrifying and I was just wondering
in your process, did you have like a
collection of these horrible things
or did you just make them
up as you went along?
>> I based them on humans.
[laughter]
[ Applause ]
I mean I don't know if you
know this about humans,
but we're both awesome
and horrifying.
So, that's the short answer to that.
And the other answer is
no I just kind of make it
up as I go along because--
but in all honesty there's no
horrifying behavior that I can give
to my aliens that humans
don't already do.
Humans, yeah, so.
[laughter].
>> Thanks for coming first of all.
>> John Scalzi: Thank you.
>> For "Lock In" you
wrote a little novella
that was the oral history
"Unlocked".
It was great and really detailed
and I was fascinated by it
and how did you decide that
you were going to write that?
What motivated you?
>> John Scalzi: Okay so the question
is I wrote a book called "Lock In"
which is actually based
here in Washington,
D.C. and then I wrote a companion
novella to it called "Unlocked"
which is the oral history of Haden's
Syndrome which is the disease
that has a central
role in "Lock In".
And the reason I wrote that
was because when I was writing
"Lock In", I was doing a huge
amount of world building.
And you actually have to
do more world building
when you're writing near
future than you have to do
when you're writing far future
because if I write something
that's 1500 years in the future,
like the "Collapsing Empire" is
supposed to be, I don't really have
to make any solid connection
between now and then.
It's 1500 years in the
future and we'll all be dead
so you can't fact check me.
[laughter] But when I write
something like "Lock In",
I know that 25 years from now,
I'm going to be at a convention
like this and someone will be
like, I was just wondering,
you wrote in "Lock In" that
this thing was going to happen
and it didn't happen so I want to
know what it's like to be a failure.
[laughter] Because nerds
are awesome that way.
[laughter] And so you actually have
to make the connections
much more robust.
That means I did a huge amount of
world building, but I wasn't able
to show it in the book necessarily
because I had a murder to solve
in the course of the book.
And so when I got done
writing "Lock In",
I was like I have all this world
building and I want to show my work.
[laughter] And literally
that's why I wrote it.
I wrote it and I like gave
it to Tor and I said here,
put it out as marketing, whatever.
Do something with it.
And they're like no, no,
we'll put it out as a novella.
So that's what they--
so that's what they did.
But yeah it was me just going look,
look, look at all the work I did!
See what I did?
See? See? Isn't this cool?
Isn't this cool?
>> It was.
It was very cool.
Thank you.
>> John Scalzi: Why, thank you.
[laughter]
[ Applause ]
Yes?
>> So like when you like wrote these
books, like when you were thinking
about it, like, did you
feel good about yourself?
Was it like a struggle or
was it like, were you feeling
like really good or were you like?
>> John Scalzi: I generally
try to feel good about myself.
[laughter] Not in, not to make
light of what you're saying,
but I think one of the things
that's really important,
one of the things that's
really difficult for writers is
to have the belief that
we know what we're doing.
There's something that
writers have and I think a lot
of creative people have and
I think a lot of humans have
and it's something that's
called imposter syndrome, right?
And imposter syndrome
means that you believe
that no matter what you're doing
or how accomplished you are
or how good it is, the thing that
you're doing, somebody's going
to find out that you have
no idea what you're doing.
And that they're going to come
and they're going to say, we know.
And then they'll go take
you to creative jail
where you will spend
the rest of your days.
And it sounds funny when I'm
talking about it this way
but it is actually a very serious
problem for writers and creators,
the feeling that there's
no rule book.
We don't know what we're doing.
We're making this up as we go along.
And the answer to that is
yes, we are making this
up as we go along, and that's okay.
And there's no way to be an
impostor as a creative person
because just the simple act
of creation itself affirms
that you know what you're
doing because you're doing it.
Now, it doesn't necessarily mean
that every creative thing you do
is good, and I stand testament
to that every time
I pick up a guitar.
[laughter] But it does mean that,
you know, anybody who decides to sit
down to write is a writer.
If you write, you are a writer.
No one can take away-- that away
from you, you are not an imposter.
So for me, when I sit down to write.
It's an affirmative thing.
It is saying this is
something I want to do.
This is something that
I enjoy doing.
I am excited to find out
what happens with this story.
So for me it's always a good thing.
>> So couldn't you just walk
through the imaginary jail
and then you could be like bye bye?
>> John Scalzi: What was that?
>> You could just be like I'm
not spending my day in here,
I just want to-- I just want to
do like, like you could just walk
through the imaginary jail then
you could be like oh and just walk
through the jail bars,
it's not a jail?
>> John Scalzi: Yeah, absolutely.
[applause] And that's, but the funny
thing is there's a lot of people
who don't realize that
they can do that.
And one of the things that we have
to do as writers and creators is
to remind each other
there is no jail.
Thank you.
Next question.
>> Hi. Listening to your stories,
I thought they were very whimsical.
>> John Scalzi: Yeah.
>> And I was wondering, is that a
tenet of science fiction writing
and is there any mystery as well?
Because I feel like I,
as a reader am attracted
to like mystery, like
unknowable things.
So [inaudible] question.
>> John Scalzi: Science fiction
has no particular rules other
than it's meant to
be science fictional.
It's meant to be speculative.
So you can put anything you
want into science fiction.
I wrote "Lock In" as a mystery
because I wanted to write a mystery
and I'm a science fiction writer,
so it made sense to do it that way.
I write humor in my science fiction
because I like writing humor.
Science fiction is not, to go
back to what we just talked about,
it's not a jail, you know?
You can do lots of
things in the field.
You just have to decide
that you want to do them.
So for me, yeah, science
fiction can be whimsical.
It can be mysterious.
It can be sexy.
Although we tend to have
a problem with that.
We need to work on our research.
[laughter] But it can it
can literally be anything.
Right here.
We're going to go through
as quickly as we can
with the people who are standing.
So quick.
>> Thank you very much.
Quick question.
Love all your characters but I
especially love Sergeant Ruiz.
>> John Scalzi: Um hum.
>> Where did he come
from if you don't mind?
>> John Scalzi: Sergeant
Ruiz, in "Old Man's War",
he was the drill instructor.
I took every single cliche about
drill instructors and I made sure
that the character
was aware of them.
[laughter] And that was pretty
much how I did that one.
Next question.
A nerdish fact check, does green
skin really make any difference
at all?
>> In my universe it does.
[laughter]
>> John Scalzi: So you've
created a lot of really fun books
and universes, which of those would
you not mind living in [inaudible]?
>> Excuse me?
>> John Scalzi: Which of your worlds
would you not mind [inaudible]?
>> I-- there are very few of my
universes that I would want to live
in because they're
designed to be fun to read
which does not necessarily
mean fun to live in.
And probably the closest to the
one that I would want to live
in would be "Lock In" but I
just know I would get sick so.
[laughter]
>> Hi. "Collapsing Empire" seems a
major tonal shift in your writing
with a lot more sex and
cursing than you usually do.
Why this change and were you worried
that some readers might
take it the wrong way?
>> Last part first, don't care.
First part, I swear a lot.
[laughter] I mean-- and I mean--
this, and it's really
actually only one character
that swears a whole lot.
It's Kiva, and that's just
part of her character matrix.
So generally speaking,
I'm writing a book now
that has very little cursing
relative to what's in that,
so and with the sex, I mean
mostly I don't write sex scenes
because I [inaudible]
through them and I feel
that that will probably
end up feeling inauthentic.
But who knows, there might be more.
So quickly.
>> "Redshirts" was really funny.
Will there be a sequel and is
the shirt you're wearing part
of the research for that?
[laughter]
>> So as I got older I
stopped wearing tee shirts
and I started wearing
Hawaiian shirts or aloha shirts
and the reason I do that is
because they are dazzle camouflage
for my middle age paunch.
[laughter] No sequel
to "Red Shirts".
Very quickly, we'll do
these like 10 seconds each.
Go!
>> So you're talking about world
building for near term and far term
and one thing I've noticed
in reading science fiction
over the decades I've been reading
it is no one saw the cell phone.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm wondering if you try
to identify a world changer
like that or do you just give up?
>> You never know.
It's going to hit you.
I mean we didn't do a real good
job finding the internet either.
>> [Inaudible] did.
>> We-- you know the thing
about it is, you know,
there will be always people
who figure out one thing
and we will always
take credit for it.
But again, we're always living
in the current so we have to work
with the metaphors that we have.
Last question very quick.
>> Also in the vein of "Redshirts",
I love how it leans very hard
on the fourth wall with
sort of a wink and a nod
at the universe and that the author.
So I ask you Kirk Picard or other?
>> For what?
[laughter] I mean for president?
[laughter] For a hot date?
I mean--
>> Take it whatever
direction you want.
>> I just-- you know,
I don't have to choose.
You know, I am poly captainal.
[laughter] Thank you everybody.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.